I want to talk about consent today,
which means I'm going to be talking about sex,
so if you're not ready to hear me,
family friendly Charlie,
talking about sex, warning: sex.
In my lifetime, I have had a grand total
of two sexual partners.
I lost my virginity when I was 21,
and it's kind of surprising to me these days how
little those quantifiers actually matter to me.
Back in school, however, my self-perceived
sexual inadequacy
seemed like the most shameful thing in the world,
like nothing was more terrifying to me than
the idea of one of my
school friends asking me how far I had gotten
with a girl,
and honestly when they did ask me, the few times
they did,
I just lied, which makes me feel like they probably
were just lying as well.
In hindsight, though, I'm very glad that I didn't
rush into anything
'cause I think it helped me to learn the
importance of, you know, not rushing.
In my experience, taking the time to really
get to know the person that you're with
and what they like makes the whole sex thing
much more enjoyable,
and it's also just a really great way to make sure
that the person that you're with really wants
to be there too.
And that is what consent is.
It's about making a positive decision that you
and the person that you're with
both definitely want to have sex together.
And for me, personally, having that mutual
consent is completely vital.
If there's ever any doubt in my mind that
the person I'm with
doesn't want to be there with me, I stop and I talk
to them about it.
It kind of ruins the flow, yeah, but it's the
right thing to do,
and it's something I think about every single
I'm with them too
because just because someone says "yes"
the first time
doesn't automatically make it a "yes" every
other time.
When I was in school, sex was talked about like it
was some kind of trophy,
like it was something you had to get to win
approval, but really,
it's something you have to get approval for from
two people:
from yourself and from the person that you're with.
If you don't, want to have sex and you're being
pressured into doing it, it's horrible -
be that through your peers making you feel bad
because you're still a virgin
or be it through you making your partner feel bad
because they aren't up for it.
Everybody always has a choice about how far
they want to go
and what they feel comfortable with.
You can't force someone into doing it,
and you can't pressure someone into doing it until
they give in either.
If the person that you're with says "no,"
then you stop,
and even if they don't say "no," even if they just
give the impression that they're not in the mood
i.e. their body language, they stop kissing you,
they just don't want to be held, then you stop.
Because in the eyes of the law, that is exactly the
same as them saying "no."
And if the person that you're with says "no" in any
of those ways
and you go ahead and have sex with them
anyway, that's rape.
That's what rape is, and if you're charged with it,
you could go to prison, you could get put on the
sex offenders register,
and it would likely seriously mess up your future.
I am assuming you don't want that, though.
When you're in the mood, and your partner isn't,
yes, it can be very frustrating,
but in my experience, there is nothing better than
being with someone
who you know definitely wants to be there with you.
Sex is great, but it is so much greater when you
can be
giving as much pleasure as you're getting.
In summary, Charlie's sexy advice is:
be safe, be smart,
be with someone who you know wants to be with
you every single time.
Don't do anything illegal, just to be safe.
And have lots of fun because sex is great,
and that's my official statement. Bye.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Okay, if you need anymore information about
relationships, about consent, or abuse,
the best thing you can do is seek help -
professional help and advice from qualified sources.
Click here to visit In The Know for more
information,
and I'll put a link in the description as well.
Thank you so much for watching,
and I really hope this helps.